hey I'll check it out so I've been
working on my third lap recently to get
my third game up - yeah mmm that's
supposed to scare you eventually like if
you want Cup no oh what is going on
YouTube now I'm pretty sure growing up a
lot of us had dreams now some of us
wanted to become and in my case some of
us wanted to be Robert
I stole the snicker once when I was kid
and I felt so guilty I just threw up on
myself but you will find out later on
crazy like that you eventually will have
to get to know yourself and sometimes
the truth hurts now I'm pretty sure you
all seen or heard about this every time
I go on and play basketball there's
always some kind of [ __ ] there's
still things they're gonna make it to
the NBA so today we're gonna talk about
your hoop and dreams and your future
career in the NBA that doesn't exist so
you already know what it is else yeah
baby let's get it let's go you are not
going to the NBA now don't want him you
wanna be like my [ __ ] you are missing a
few things to your equation let's start
with skills height the ability not to
suck ass and sometimes you ain't black
now I get it you love the sport every
week you watch basketball on TV with a
bag of Cheetos on your pickle belly and
you want Pitt you want to get on the
court
do a 360 move windmills off somebody's
face oh but let me tell you something
it's not going to happen
you sir are out of shape whose you don't
think you are [ __ ] you ever
cheerleaders have the same cup size that
is a
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] when you lay up you just
lay down get it aside when you're
watching the game and you already
sweated through your Jersey and your
t-shirt you just might be out of shape
remember that one times I'm going
through that sticker on the floor and
you stop by like 30 seconds during a
game is that a snigger you're too short
I don't know what you're gonna say Nate
Rogers is short look at him
that's right [ __ ] look at him he got
skills hops SP any black [ __ ]
you ain't got none of that
look here frodo baggins you wanna when
your kid win built up and five foot
nothing better come talk to me with your
Navi a sneak do you realize that when
you are 5 foot 2 with a whole bunch of
7-foot brothers on the court you're just
walking into like six-six every three
seconds
come on my next [ __ ] the only boss you
go and touch of the ball sex on your
face you suck now listen I understand
when you want to rake in the basketball
court and you follow up all these little
13 year olds you pretty go but guess
what they're not in the NBA either [ __ ]
you will get [ __ ] up on an NBA Court
like nobody's business
now mind you I'm not telling you to stop
playing basketball play basketball it's
a great sport but listen you're not
gonna make it to the NBA have fun enjoy
the sport I play all the time and let me
tell you something I'm pretty you know
I'm you know none of your business [ __ ]
but I had when you play basketball the
quarter people always cause the seeds -
mm [ __ ] [ __ ] I go fat put on the same
team nah but you like swung at the ball
in the air when in my mouth no as I
heard
nobody's gonna give you a ring or a
trophy you're not getting paid [ __ ] you
want to foul I'll show you a foul
[ __ ] go for layup
cut you like your balls and you fall
down see what all of your testicles I do
but when you play basketball you suck
why you gotta learn like you hit
a wristband and two shooter sleeves hmm
[ __ ] all those accessories are
not going to give you a layup and a jump
shot you look stupid
that's all the in here does in high
school when they were put a spoiler on
the back of the car they thought it
would make go faster no man you see my
new spoiler a buck my car go faster
we cut the end of a pair will be could
it make the Magna engine look I don't
know man look just really come on nobody
this is not for young people who want to
make it to the NBA if you want to go to
the NBA put the time scale of practice
into it and I guarantee you can do it
this video is gonna kick to all those 30
or 40 girls who got knobby knees and big
kiddies flopping about on the court
talking about they wanna make it to the
NBA
kill yourself what you think gotta go to
the NBA to be a great ball player in my
friends look at me i freshen my left
ankle am I ready to go edit or my right
ACL and I'm not gonna be anymore
I know that right right you know what
there's somebody's like a 240-pound
point guard you don't say nobody but
[ __ ] you then [ __ ] you don't want me on
your team anyways please yeah I keep
Betty rabbit Simon Christon wanna ride
me keep mo bills in the Cosby I figure I
can look Kaka things might get low ride
like that on my ear sipping okay
[Music]
oh my god